- [Instructor] Let's say
we have a pure sample
of phosphorus pentachloride,
and we add the PCl5 to a
previously evacuated flask
at 500 Kelvin.
And let's say the initial
pressure of the PCl5
is 1.66 atmospheres.
Some of the PCl5 is going
to turn into PCl3 and Cl2.
Once equilibrium is
reached, the total pressure,
let's say, is measured
to be 2.35 atmospheres.
Our goal is to calculate the
equilibrium partial pressures
of these three substances,
so PCl5, PCl3 and Cl2.
And from those equilibrium
partial pressures,
we can also calculate the Kp value
for this reaction at 500 Kelvin.
To help us find the
equilibrium partial pressures,
we're gonna use an ICE
table where I stands
for the initial partial
pressure in atmospheres,
C is the change in partial pressure,
and E stands for the
equilibrium partial pressure.
We already know we're starting
with a partial pressure of
1.66 atmospheres for PCl5.
And if we assume that the
reaction hasn't started yet,
we're starting with zero
for our partial pressures
of PCl3 and Cl2.
Some of the PCl5 is going to decompose.
And since we don't know how much,
we're gonna call that amount x.
So, we're gonna write minus x here,
since we're gonna lose some PCl5.
Next, we need to look at mole ratios.
So, the mole ratio of PCl5
to PCl3 is one to one.
So, for losing x for PCl5,
we must be gaining x for PCl3.
The same idea with Cl2,
the coefficient in the
balanced equation is a one.
So, if we're losing x for PCl5,
that means we're gaining x for Cl2.
Therefore, the equilibrium
partial pressure for PCl5
would be 1.66 minus x.
The equilibrium partial pressure for PCl3
would be zero plus x, which is just x.
And the equilibrium
partial pressure for Cl2
would be zero plus x, which is also x.
To figure out what x is, we're
going to use Dalton's law.
And Dalton's law says
that the total pressure
of a mixture of gases is equal to the sum
of the individual partial pressures
of the gases in the mixture.
So, we said that the total pressure
of all the gases at equilibrium
is equal to 2.35 atmospheres.
So, we can plug that into Dalton's law.
And then, we can take the
equilibrium partial pressures
from our ICE table and plug
those into Dalton's law as well.
So, we're gonna plug in 1.66 minus x
for the equilibrium
partial pressure of PCl5,
x for the equilibrium
partial pressure of PCl3,
and x for the equilibrium
partial pressure of PCl2.
So, let's plug in 1.66 minus x.
And then, we have plus x and plus x.
And let's solve for x.
Notice how we have a minus x and a plus x.
So, that cancels out.
So, we simply subtract 1.66 from 2.35
and we find that x is equal to .69.
So, if x is equal to .69,
the equilibrium partial pressure
of Cl2 is .69 atmospheres.
And the equilibrium partial pressure PCl3
is also .69 atmospheres.
And 1.66 minus .69 gives us
the equilibrium partial pressure of PCl5
and that's equal to .97 atmospheres.
Now that we have our
equilibrium partial pressures
for all three gases,
we can calculate the value
for the equilibrium constant
for this reaction at 500 Kelvin.
First, we need to write an
equilibrium constant expression.
So, we would write Kp is equal
to, and for our products,
we have PCl3, so this would be
the partial pressure of PCl3
times the partial pressure
of our other product,
which is Cl2, so let's put in there
the partial pressure of Cl2.
And all of that is divided by
the partial pressure of PCl5.
So, this would be the
partial pressure of PCl5.
Next, we plug in our
equilibrium partial pressures.
So, the equilibrium partial
pressure of PCl3 is .69.
The equilibrium partial
pressure of Cl2 is also .69.
And the equilibrium partial
pressure of PCl5 is .97.
Once we plug our numbers in and we solve,
we get that Kp is equal
to .49 at 500 Kelvin.